very sad news that we woke up to this
morning a really big loss to the
activism community congressman Elijah
Cummings a real civil rights era hero
has died at age 68 his office reports
the cause of death as quote
complications concerning long-standing
health challenges it's known that he had
a procedure recently the full details of
everything that he was battling have not
been made public and Cummings has been
visible recently as a House Democrat
because he's been involved in
investigations into Donald Trump he was
involved in some key questioning of
Donald Trump's former personal attorney
Michael Cohen before Cohen went to
prison when he testified before a number
of committees he was involved in a
horrible controversy with Donald Trump
about rodent infested Baltimore but this
is a man with a life of civil rights
activism under his belt he was a lawyer
by education but really an activist at
heart he had 12 honorary Doctorate
degrees when he was 11 years old he
helped to racially integrate a local
swimming pool while being attacked with
bottles and rocks in the Maryland House
of Delegates he was the youngest
chairman of the legislative black caucus
also the first black American to be
Speaker Pro temp and more recently he's
been on the forefront of political
battles around the shootings of unarmed
black men of Trump's impeachment the
immigration crisis child internment
camps really a loss and I'm sure we'll
be looking at more and more of his
accomplishments but just a bad week of
news all around out of the Middle East
out of the White House everywhere and
really sad news to wake up to this
morning Elijah Cummings dead at 68 and
we will be talking more about this
upcoming